we ran a third world election  and things are coming out over the next  couple of days maybe even today we're  always days away from the Blockbuster  one case I think a very big story is  coming out today on the cheating  and  numerous states are going to be turned I  don't know what they're going to do but  it's going to show that they were won by  me it's already shown right if you look  at if you look at Arizona if you look at  the findings in Arizona is it sad at  this point guys  that it's still the same talking points  that's over right we want it and I'm  going to go out there next week we're  making a speech but if you look at those  findings we won the state so Trump did  not win Arizona now then Trump goes back  to talking about the size of his  pathetic crowd he again is talking about  crowd size I I know it's 20 22.